everybody is still freaking out that
Disney and Sony were able to come to
terms and an agreement about spider-man
staying in the MCU how's it going
everybody it's Warren and if this is the
first time that you are hearing this
news it is official
spider-man is back in the MCU and of
course everybody is super excited about
it Marvel had big plans for spider-man
to lead the future Avengers in the MCU
so it looks like the current path of the
MCU that Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios had planned out is still
going to be the same because not only is
spider-man back in the MCU but we also
have the date of the next spider-man
film so we have the date and the
official new terms that Sony and Disney
agreed to with spider-man I'll talk
about these terms the release date and
what it means for the future of the MCU
in this video quick reminder to
subscribe to my channel for your chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm picking
a giveaway winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so originally
with the deal that Disney and Sony had
together for the first fighter man films
that we saw Disney was only getting five
percent of the first dollar gross and
according to deadline.com Disney at one
point asked for fifty percent now Sony
said no but the new terms of this
contract are 25 percent this means that
Marvel / Disney will co-financed 25
percent of the third Home Coming movie
for a 25 percent equity stake simply put
they pay for 25 percent of the
production and they get 25 percent of
the money that the movie mix now this
really is a big win for both parties yes
Sony has given up more than they were
before but they get to keep Kevin Feige
and Kevin Feige has been very heavily
involved with the creative aspect when
it comes to Tom Hollands spider-man and
of course there are a number of factors
but Kevin Feige is a big reason why
spider-man was so successful so Kevin
Feige still gets to head the spider-man
films which in turn will make spider-man
a more money which in turn will make
Sony more money so Sony wins there but
of course Disney and Marvel went as well
because spider-man gets to stay in the
MCU and they get to make more money off
him now and that's fair because Tom
Holland was specifically cast as
spider-man for the MCU Kevin Feige and
Amy Pascal and the Russo brothers as
well are the ones who chose Tom Holland
specifically for a spider-man in the MCU
and with this new deal Amy Pascal will
officially be the one who is going to
produce this film through Pascal
pictures this works out perfectly
because Amy Pascal produced the first
two spider-man movies as well so overall
all parties involved kind of win here
and that's why they came to an agreement
and with that agreement officially comes
the third spider-man in the MCU
scheduled for release on July 16th of
2021 and this third spider-man film was
going to be a big film for the MCU Tom
Hollands spider-man is supposed to go on
to lead the Avengers and let's not
forget that a few months ago there were
many reports stating that Marvel is
looking for a way to introduce Deadpool
in the MCU and they were eyeing
spider-man 3 for their chance to do that
so now that spider-man is officially
coming back to the MCU and we have all
of these Fox characters Deadpool
included that need to be introduced into
the MCU and not to mention that Ryan
Reynolds did tease the fact that
Deadpool is coming to the MCU as well we
could be seeing Deadpool appear in
spider-man 3 and that would also attract
many more people to see the film which
would of course make more money for the
film which would of course make Disney
and Sony more money which of course is
something that everybody wants after
they struck this deal with each other so
there are really big plans for
spider-man 3 Sony held on to spider-man
with everything they had and Disney and
Marvel settled for less than what they
wanted just because they want spider-man
to remain in the MCU so we have a lot to
look forward to so these are the new
terms for the spider-man contract Disney
and Marvel will co-financed 25% of the
films and they will get 25% of the
revenue in return Pascal Pictures will
produce the film and the third
spider-man film is scheduled for release
on July 16th of 2021
I'll link the full report in the
description down below if you want to
check it out for yourself but let me
know what you think about this new deal
and let me know if you would like to see
Deadpool get introduced into the MCU in
spider-man 3 let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and also
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and if you'd
also like a chance to win a 10
switch be sure to follow me on Twitter
and click the link in the description
down below as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof